[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fritzi was embarrassed to say that he
went to see the elvis movie and then
came back and he was doing his elvis
impersonation he was singing he was
dancing
and now you're the biggest you're the
biggest elvis fan 50 years after he died
i really am i can't stop like singing
and trying to do impersonations of him
i'm really annoying my family a lot and
us too and you guys yeah seton i feel
like there's nothing wrong with going to
see that movie what todd should be
questioning is that he went to go see it
with uh his daughter and her boyfriend
i did it
it's a little tricky
the daughter and the boyfriend sat in
the front that me and the wife in the
back and everybody behaved didn't know
richard roper does this for a living he
reviews films for the chicago sun times
and you can check out screen time with
roe and roper podcast all summer long he
and ro khan have been celebrating the uh
anniversary years of certain movies and
tv shows latest one is about the summer
of 1982 one of the greatest movie
summers of all time good to have him
back what is the greatest aside from
1939
greatest year modern day
greatest year for movies is what
well 94 it was a great year with the you
know pulp fiction and forrest gump and a
lot of great films but dan the summer
just the summer of 1982
just in the summer e.t
poltergeist the thing fast times at
ridgemont high rocky iii
blade runner an officer and a gentleman
all within a three-month period in the
summer of 82.
i mentioned tom cruise is the last movie
star
you agree
yes
especially when you think about the
longevity because you want to talk about
going back 1983 was risky business so he
has been a
top level global superstar
for 40 years
i don't think anybody's ever going to do
that again it's sort of like when we
look at certain players in in baseball
and the records they have that are never
going to be matched again you know so if
somebody right now is a is a big star
ryan gosling or scarlett johansson
they'd have to do it for 30 more years
at that level and
he's got that combination of he's i
think he's an underrated actor you know
you look at things like magnolia and
born on the 4th of july you know oscar
nominated performances but he also knows
how to sell the movies he knows how to
do it internationally and he knows how
to carry a movie you know so he he
probably is really the last major movie
star it's like tom brady or lebron james
to have that longevity to play at a high
level for that amount of time and he is
into fatiguable i mean his energy in
selling a movie and and i mentioned this
yesterday
he's single-handedly getting people back
to the theater yeah which is amazing
made billions of dollars and you know if
people go see top gun maverick they go
to the multiplex they go oh wow you know
this is playing there as well elvis is
playing there maybe we'll come back so
it's just it's like getting people back
to the ballpark you know after after
covent he is a huge attraction
is maverick um a a great movie or a good
movie it's a good movie uh you know you
go back and look at the first one it's
absolutely ludicrous but it was you know
the thing about it was everybody got to
show off their brand new basement
theater sound systems in the 80s they'd
always play the first 10 minutes of top
gun and go look at this you know and
then rattling the walls in the basement
what they did the smart thing with uh
top gun maverick dan is they just
basically did a tribute to top gun it's
the same story just next generation
great casting bringing in miles teller
to play the son of goose the anthony
edwards character and then you know the
kind of touching inclusion of val kilmer
who's you know battling the same sort of
illness that his character has in the
movie and cruz is he is amazing because
again you believe that this guy
really still would be trusted with a
billion dollar
jet even though he's at the age where he
should be a rear admiral and retired and
smoking a cigar right
well also and i don't know why did it
take so long
to get the sequel made
and was that a good thing that it took
this long yeah i think it was you know a
lot of cases if you wait too long the
the interest has died off but as we've
talked about cruz has remained a huge
movie star he was adamant that this was
going to be a theatrical release there
were multiple delays with pandemic and
injuries on the set and all that and he
they waited to the right time to release
it as well when just about everybody's
ready to go back to theaters to the
ballparks to restaurants so it was just
the kind of the perfect storm for this
to come out
would you bet there will be a top gun
three i hope not
you know i mean
at some point you know it's gonna be top
walker you know that kind of limps into
that we're gonna go we're gonna go win
the war i think and again i think you
know cruz is great about this dan with
franchises you look at mission
impossible that's one of the few movie
franchises that has actually gotten
better with every succeeding film the
first two were just okay john woo did i
think the second one but they've become
james bond movies they become born
movies you know it's it's got nothing to
do anymore with the original mission
impossible tv series that's gone that's
in the past he's just playing a
character who has the same name as that
character
i go back to 1986 ferris bueller color
money aliens platoon stand by me top gun
hoosiers river's edge
a pretty good run there that's a great
run and you talk about that that that
list of films the ones from
82 we're talking about some of them are
action films but a lot of them are those
the movies that i think you and i love
the most which are character driven
story driven incredible screenplays and
that's why those movies resonate 40
years later because it's it's not about
the time that they're in it's about the
characters and the situation people can
still relate to ferris bueller even
though every move he pulls right now
would be busted by cell phones he'd
never get away with any of that stuff
but it doesn't matter it's sort of like
seinfeld where it's the situation of the
sitcom that we can relate to generations
later i wonder how this has impacted
acting
that you know if before you were an
actor not you know something with
prosthetics or you were in a marvel
movie or something cgi
is it fair to look at actors now can you
compare them to a previous generation
i mean it feels like everything is a
marvel movie and i don't know if actors
grow up to be i want to be in a marvel
movie as opposed to
you know these movies that i mentioned
that are character driven no that's a
great point dan you look like the
upcoming thor
sequel love and thunder which i keep
thinking of like an australian male
stripper group when i hear thor loving
thunder it's like down under vegas yeah
down under but you know the the co-stars
of that movie along with chris hemsworth
natalie portman christian bale russell
crowe academy award winner academy award
winner academy award winner and not to
disparage the marvel material but you
know that deep in their hearts those
three could be doing shakespeare on
stage somewhere you know so do they do
it for the paychecks and the popularity
i think yeah and it's a certain style of
acting you know you're with the green
screen and you have to kind of suspend
your own disbelief but i think that's
why so many great actors now turn to
streaming series where they can get
showcase roles that are about the
writing in the character we're talking
to richard roper he's a movie critic for
uh chicago's sun times your review of
elvis is what
i thought it was terrific um and fritz
should not be embarrassed about seeing
it just just remember this one thing in
life nobody ever says hey do your elvis
impersonation for me ever nobody has
ever said that in history but what i
loved first of all this is baslerman he
did you know he did great gatsby romeo
and juliet moulin rouge you know what
you're going to get with him a lot of
razzle dazzle going back to the theme
you got to see this on the big screen
what i loved about this first of all was
this
austin butler who's playing elvis that
they didn't cast to harry styles or
somebody who's super talented but super
well known most people don't know us in
butler he was great at tax watson and
once upon a time in hollywood small but
pivotal role but largely an unknown so
we could buy into him
as elvis presley and i think he does a
terrific job that's a great point that's
and we've seen these biopics do well
you had ray uh walk the line uh bohemian
rhapsody
um
i guess the elton john one didn't work
uh you know with a critical
or you know as far as awards uh
yeah yeah well because again it was sort
of like even though bosnian directed it
was a very stylized thing but what i one
of the things i loved about the elvis
movie dan was that the the the various
periods of elvis's career are kind of
filmed in the style of the time so
there's more of a sepia grainy tone to
the 50s stuff when they talk about his
movie career it's split screen and it's
done in that kind of larger eye-popping
colors of the 60s and then the comeback
special all the way through the vegas
stuff so it has almost even though it's
wildly over the top it also has kind of
a docudrama feel to it oh that's cool uh
did you review hustle the movie i star
in
listen
your boy when he puts his mind to it can
really do some really good stuff i was a
huge fan of uncut gems and i loved
hustle and one of the things i loved
about athena is you could just see
adam sandler's love for the game in
every scene there you know it really
just it really got into it and it's a
celebration like it's a celebration of
the athleticism and the poetry of
basketball so many of those scenes not
we didn't get a lot of big game scenes
we got workout scenes and we got street
ball scenes and playground scenes and i
thought that was great and i thought the
various athletes who played roles not
just played themselves were terrific
anthony edwards i i got a screening back
in february and uh you know the
timberwolf star i said this guy
you would not know that he played in the
nba if you i thought he was he jumped
off the screen i thought he was that
charismatic he was the apollo creed of
the story and you're right if you know a
lot of even though he's a real real
talent and a young star you know when
you're playing for the timberwolves okay
you know he's not nationally he doesn't
have the face of a steph curry or lebron
or anybody like that yet uh and you you
if you didn't know that you'd think they
found a really good actor who could play
basketball instead of the other way
around all right three movies that my
audience should see this summer are
well the black phone which just came out
i love this it's an old-fashioned horror
film with ethan hawk playing against
type as a serial killer and i love that
it's set in 1978 which is the year that
halloween came out so it has almost that
kind of vibe of a halloween movie
psychological thriller uh i'm really
looking forward to
uh nope which is the latest horror film
from jordan peel i haven't seen it yet
and what i love about this film is we
know almost nothing about it it's got
something to do with horses that's about
all we know about that you got one more
uh the forgiven uh jessica chastain and
ray fines and this is kind of an
old-fashioned film noir you know they're
the wealthy couple they go to morocco
and they get involved in a murder and a
cover-up and it's about cultures
clashing and again it goes back to great
actors with great roles just knocking it
out of the park the movie that we should
not see
uh
well i i didn't like the jurassic movie
and um
this this this recent one the man from
toronto with kevin hart who i love and
woody harry i watched that yesterday
yeah i mean he's played that role like
in 20 movies right the you know the
amiable bumbling guy who finds himself
in a situation over his head and then
all kinds of guns
shots and explosions yeah we've seen it
a million times yeah
all right it's good to touch base with
you um you know i'm put i'm racking up
numbers here with uh
cameos so in memoriam i'm i'm i'm
getting i mean look if you live longer
than i do
can you just get me up on the big screen
in memoriam at the academy awards yeah i
think the key is we're gonna we're gonna
give you the box office credit you know
like like john ratzenberger who's in all
the pixar movies who was cliff on chairs
and he has one role so he's got a box
office of like seven billion okay you're
well over the billion yeah
so we'll go with that we'll go with that
yeah i'm still waiting for you to break
down all the cameos that i've done
i mean it's a very a very maybe a very
special podcast we can i would be you
know more than happy i i forget some of
the movies that i i'm trying to forget
some of the movies i've been on yeah but
my job is to remind you yes
that's true richard great to talk to you
again thank you my friend that's richard
roper chicago sun times film and uh tv
critic
hopefully he doesn't
be a critic on this show